une course-poursuite en tout tout au
Maroc en 1969
pour guider l'aventurier Indiana Jones
dans le labyrinthe des ruelles il y a
Teddy
interprété par Ethan Isidore le jeune
homme de 16 ans mène une vie simple de
lycéens à Orléans qui paraît loin du
star system et des gros tournage
américain on a l'impression d'être dans
le film et de vivre l'aventure avec des
personnages réels et personne n'est au
courant parce que tout est confidentiel
donc c'est un peu particulier parce que
on va on va acheter du pain et le soir
on rentre et on se bat contre des nazis
et
pour commencer je vais vous raconter ma
vie ok depuis qu'il est tout petit Ethan
joue la comédie devant la caméra de sa
maman
plus à 10 ans il passe son premier vrai
casting et il enchaîne les courts
métrages jusqu'à l'audition qui va
changer sa vie et là on est parti à
Londres pour rencontrer le réalisateur
et ensuite quelques jours plus tard on
se baladait là il nous appelle et ils
nous disent que je suis pris et que je
vais jouer dans Indiana Jones et du coup
on a pleuré et c'était peut-être les
meilleurs minutes de ma vie je pense
pourtant Ethan n'est pas au bout de ses
émotions pour la promo du film le jeune
élève de seconde montre les marches du
festival de Cannes aux côtés de la
légende Harrison Ford et le plus
impressionné n'est pas forcément celui
qu'on croit une tasse
il est très naturel
il est fait pour raconter des histoires
c'est un super mec et ce ne sont pas les
camarades de classe des Times qui diront
le contraire même s'ils sont quand même
un petit peu impressionnés
c'est incroyable en fait mais en même
temps c'est mon ami du coup bah on parle
pas que de ça non plus à y croire en
fait même quand je vois les extraits
j'arrive pas à voir que c'est la
personne à qui je peux avec qui je peux
rigoler avec qui je peux même demander
de sortir juste pour traîner car oui
Ethan n'a pas complètement changé de vie
pour ne pas prendre la grosse tête sur
la Croisette rien de mieux qu'un bon
vieux retour à la vraie vie
c'était vraiment un moment où j'avais
l'impression d'être important et ensuite
trois jours plus tard j'étais retour en
cours avec mon prof de maths franchement
ça fait ça fait plaisir et on est un peu
fier quand même de voir qui s'épanouit
comme ça et que ça le rend que ça le
rend heureux vraiment la semaine
prochaine Ethan va retrouver Harrison
Ford les photographes et les paillettes
ils s'envolera pour une autre avant
première d'Indiana Jones 5 à Los Angeles
tout en gardant les pieds sur terre